they get steering it was dough balls day
as another celebrity joined the labor
mix the shadow chancellor and celebrity
chef Delia Smith are long-standing
friends with a shared passion for
norwich city football club and today she
became his political supporter publicly
endorsing labor I'm now very privileged
to be here among you and to be able to
introduce to you the next prime minister
of england ed miliband Delia is the
latest in a string of celebrities who've
taken to the stage at labor rounds
perhaps more surprising though is that
the man who encouraged people not to
vote Russell Brand having met Ed
Miliband now wants people to vote for
labor if you're Scottish you don't need
an English person telling you what to do
to know what you're going to be doing if
you're in Brighton I think it will be a
travesty if we lost the voice of
Caroline Lucas in Westminster but
anywhere else you've gotta vote labour
you've got to get the Conservative Party
out of government in this country David
Cameron called branded joke but with
nine million Twitter followers perhaps
ed Miliband will be the one laughing
brand did make unrepeated Lee rude
remarks about Ed Balls but that all
seems to have been forgotten however
people in Brighton today weren't
convinced i just don't think I've got
any time him at all whatever politicians
support side I've got no time for
Russell Brand so these two teachers can
use encouraging obesity you gonna vote
no not registered to vote no yayaya you
are registered to maybe you're not going
to if nothing else celebrities have
pulling power for example ed Miliband's
youtube video a portrait had less than
eighty thousand views whereas Labour's
video with Martin Freeman had 280,000
roots the combination of social media
and celebrity could be potent in
engaging young voters labour will make
sure the economy works for all of us not
just the privileged few like me Gary
Barlow campaigned for the Conservatives
in 2010 but this time most of their
endorsements have come from the business
community
of course celebrity endorsement doesn't
bring instant popularity as Jim Murphy
and ideas are discovered today in
Scotland but performers know how to
express themselves and might have the
appeal to get swing voters crossing over
Jason Farrell Sky News